des fois il faut retourner le produit et
puis aider en dessous puis non ça serait
bien s'il était visible tout de suite un
nouvel étiquetage j'arrivera bientôt en
épicerie un logo comme celui-ci sur le
devant des emballages alimentaires
riches en gras saturés en sucre et en
sel qui complètera le tableau des
valeurs nutritives le nouveau symbole
nutritionnel sur le devant des
emballages et distinctifs très visible
et facile à identifier ce qui permet aux
consommateurs de rapidement faire de
bons choix et tu fais une scène
une forte consommation de gras de sucre
ou de sodium peut contribuer au
développement de maladies chroniques le
gouvernement estime que cet étiquetage
sera un moyen rapide de reconnaître les
options plus saines et les consommateurs
justement ils sont favorables j'ai un
problème de cholestérol de sucre et de
gros donc avec ça je vais être capable
de
d'étalonner ou de comprendre qu'est-ce
que ça serait quand même plus pratique
de les avoir en avant des fois je pense
que ça changerait certains choix des
fois l'aliment qu'on fait parce que
quand on est prêt ou quoi que ce soit on
se donne pas toujours la peine de
regarder l'étiquetage en arrière tout ce
qui est bartend craquelin collation mais
préparer souvent quand je vois des
clients en consultation c'est ça qui
porte le plus sa confusion qu'est-ce qui
est mieux parce que ça ressemble tous
mais il y a des bêtes différentes au
niveau des valeurs donc ça va être
vraiment plus facile de faire des choix
éclairés pour ça un tel symbole sera
exigé sur la plupart mais pas la
totalité des produits emballés parmi les
exemptions on compte les fruits et
légumes le lait les œufs les viandes et
volailles hachées crues l'industrie
alimentaire a jusqu'au 1er janvier 2026
pour s'ajuster certaines compagnies
pourraient toutefois faire les
modifications avant ici aimer le mieux
Radio-Canada Montréal